we have that story uh well i'll just
pull up the article we had the story i
covered this earlier in the morning
macomb county man says he was targeted
with explosives due to his politics
two mortars a common weapon used by
antifa was thrown
thrown into his house by somebody drove
by got out chucked him into his house
exploded get a big old trump sign now we
don't know if this is politically
motivated
but it's an example of social media
breeding this tribalistic hatred
but here's here's what i don't
understand then if the cia
is as good as the as good as they are
what they do
why are they allowing it why are why why
would they allow this country to
eviscerate itself
that's a very good question because uh
it
it it does essentially mean people are
shooting themselves in the foot but
when we look at the history of the cia
they have a long history of doing a lot
of immoral
illegal things that haven't been done
ethically but all right here's my
question are they doing i don't know
that they make it for the country to
strengthen the country or what
now there's a good analogy here to
really kind of consider and to think
about if you
were a farm owner and you had a whole
bunch of wild animals all over the place
would it be better for you to subjugate
them to control them to lock them up in
cages and to do what you want them to do
or would you want a farm to be free
roaming and running around and i think
there's an element of this that we do
have to understand that there are
individuals
that do want to subjugate individuals to
benefit off of them and i think
that is true now the motives of the cia
we don't know
we just know their history which is
riddled in in
a lot of seedy illegal illicit
activities
heart attack guns who in their right
mind creates a heart attack gun
and that's verified from the beginning
like
like secretly killing the king you know
poisoning them or doing it so that you
don't have to be involved it's just that
it's the way things
when you make excuses for the greater
good you're essentially becoming a large
problem for everyone but you're you're
convincing yourself that you're
doing it for the you know righteous
causes and when you have a limited power
that's unchecked
unlimited money that they just get
blanket
you know sent to them no matter what
that that drives a person
insane and when we look at the cia when
we look at presidents that try to
curtail their power
what has happened to that things kennedy
kennedy notably spoke out against the
cia
trump as well so oh yeah but trump also
kind of flip-flopped on that but but
there were times where he went at them
pretty hard pretty significantly yep
and then we had a whistleblower come out
don't say his name yes and he worked
with the cia
exactly and he it was it was ridiculous
just
absolutely it was the pretext for
impeachment and now we have
have you seen what what recently came
out with democracy institute
their pollsters they predicted trump was
going to win based on several metrics
they this guy came out recently on on uh
life
liberty and levin on fox news and said
not only
did uh joe biden or i i shouldn't say
not only but i'll say this is my
personal opinion
he pointed out there are non-polling
bellwether metrics that are never wrong
never wrong like uh party registration
and voter enthusiasm
never wrong joe biden not only beat
every single bellwether metric that was
against him
he won in almost every single bellwether
area region so you've got the three
bellwether states he lost all of them
and you've got 19 bellwether townships
he he lost
18. yeah so you you hear about this kind
of stuff
and sam harris i did a segment about
this earlier sam harris was talking
about
he he tweeted uh story from the new york
times why why do people believe the
election was rigged
what rational thinking person hears that
joe biden who didn't campaign who was
in his basement half the time had no one
show up to his rallies
failed in every bellwether metric so
these are again
registration numbers across the state
the amount of primary votes he got
the uh the media attention he got google
searches he got
mask sales more silly mask and cookie
sales but these do
always show who wins and 18 out of 19
bellwether townships and the three
bellwether states
that all happened ignore all other
accusations of fraud or whatever
and then you come out and say that a
regular person is going to be like
but then he made another a better point
he said show someone the data from the
night of the election
that trump had improved his vote count
uh among the working class
the white working class minorities the
black community
and they would easily conclude he was
over performing for an incumbent and was
clearly the winner
but after all of that joe biden is the
single
greatest president in american history
who got more votes than barack obama
who had tens of thousands of people
rallying for him one of the most popular
presidents in history
who holds a 95 95 plus approval ring
among democrats
then people say you take that and i'm
not talking about fraud
then you take the down ballot victories
and the oh
the under votes in the hundreds of
thousands for joe biden and then you ask
people if they believe that joe biden
won and they're gonna tell you no i'm
sorry
when you say down bow victors that means
a bunch of republicans the republicans
won in every state
race they want every state they won uh
uh
they they won massive gains in the house
and are just doing better and better as
time goes on
they uh they held the senate so it was
tremendous tremendous other pollsters
have said
that this looks like your typical
incumbent victory
the incumbent is on the ticket people go
to vote for him and they vote down
ballot
in favor of the party so the party wins
joe biden the greatest president in
american history
congratulations million votes and
historically the incumbent always
usually gets in
except so i'm not i i am not saying i
need fraud at all you're just saying
aliens
no yes right alien now listen listen
what i'm saying right now i am not
accusing anybody of fraud
okay you can talk about the evidence
that's i'm just pointing out
joe biden did all of these things and
that being true these are all true
things
joe biden is the greatest president in
american history period end of question
no that's it that's it that's the only
conclusion is that newsguard approved
yes everything i pointed out is is is is
absolutely fact the bellwether districts
the metrics it's a these are facts
i feel like i just ran have you ever
you've probably experienced this where
you've always
got florida hard you work out and you're
just you're done and when nothing
matters
you're just so exhausted when trump all
that matters is that you can relax and
that's how i feel about this election
like there's just
how can we do we can't prove anything i
mean maybe that's maybe that's hyperbole
maybe we can prove things
when trump won iowa on election night i
remember when people were like whoa
there it is trump just won iowa
meaningless
yeah i mean there's also talk about
trump literally trying to announce that
he's going to be running for 2024.
he said there's there's a video of him
saying it so uh i mean
man we're living in interesting times to
say the least it's ridiculous
if look if everyone that went down went
down trump's not going to win in 2024.
if he's not winning now and everyone
else is it's over and i'll tell you this
i think the democrats are going to win
in georgia too
if they do that means they're going to
be controlling all of the government
except for the supreme court
no you're wrong they're going to pass
them immediately if they do pack the
courts
yes they're going to add four justices
make it a seven or six mate
but doesn't the republicans have the
senate
no if they win if the democrats win the
two seats in georgia the tiebreaker is
kamala harris
oh and i don't look
the the georgia runoff race trump's not
on the ticket
they needed trump to win it didn't work
in 2018 without trump
the new york times even reported three
recounts now in georgia
sort of sort of trump wants a hard
signature audit where they compare
uh there's also reports that the chain
of custody was broken on absentee
ballots for like a hundred thousand plus
and they just don't care the judges
don't care the judges are like
i am not going to be the person who says
i i object to this right so
we would rather have these weird like
so uh a probably a better example would
be the 20
000 names the database from the voter
integrity project of people who
didn't live in georgia lived in other
states and voted twice
the judges in these cases are like i
don't want to hear it i don't want to
hear it
i'm not i'm not getting involved we
don't have the judges who will do
anything about it
i'm not saying widespread fraud did
anything other than you know uh
the we i'm i'm not saying it caused any
change in the election i'm just saying
joe biden is the greatest president in
the history of the united states he got
the most votes
no no the greatest um he hasn't even
president no no no
hold on a man who doesn't need to
campaign
all right to get 80 million votes truly
amazing talking about magnetic
oh yeah very prolific speaker
everyone loves you you can point out
that people hate trump
but come on man nobody loves fighting so
do you think it's still
going to go to the supreme court uh it
is
so i don't know what the latest news is
because we've been preparing for this
show but tomorrow is the safe harbor
deadline
for uh the electoral college and there
are
active lawsuits in several states so i
don't know if
congress or state legislatures might try
and say
the results were contested the safe
hearted harbor deadline passed we did
not certify
uh we did not we not resolve the
disputes to certification we'll do it
come on
man the left is arguing that because
they're already certified
we're done the electors are going but in
georgia
they're trying to call a special session
and the governor who's a republican said
no i won't do it
in pennsylvania they tried doing it but
in pennsylvania the supreme court has
requested the response from state
lawyers
as to the constitutionality of mail-in
voting by tomorrow morning
arizona we just saw kelly ward uh
file to the supreme court of arizona
trying to decertify the results
i'm not saying anything's going to
happen i'm just saying that's where
we're at so far
and tomorrow is probably when we get a
better picture of what's going to happen
but you know just across the board every
step of the way trump has been
you know kind of losing out he's had
he's had some major political victories
but he's had major like legislative
failures yeah losses i should say
a lot of people are describing this as
the last stand that if
there's something not overturned or if
the supreme court doesn't
you know make a decision here that if
the democrats get control of the
congress of the senate
of the white house the house of the
senate and then potentially also the
supreme court if they pack it it's
going to be total game over there's
going to be a lot of open immigration
that's going to turn
a lot of blue cities more blue there's
going to be a lot of
more mailing voting there's going to be
a lot more
changed laws that are going to make it
absolutely impossible for another
republican
to uh come in you know you know a siphon
works
no you do you know how it works um where
you suck on it and then it starts
flowing
yeah so uh basically you can take a body
of water at a higher altitude a higher
level
say altitude and uh uh you know and then
you have your
tube from there and down what happens is
once once the water reaches
a certain threshold above and then goes
lower in the tube it pulls down creating
vacuum force which pulls up
the reason i bring that up is that we
are on the cusp of that water in the
siphon
breaking the point by which the water
will never stop flowing and that is if
the democrats
take control of everything like you said
a bunch of open immigration policies
right
which will will continually skew the
country further and further to the left
unraveling it and republicans will only
be able to argue
in favor but less in favor this is why
the event
this is why the democrats love open
immigration one it provides very cheap
labor for the corporations that
sometimes are compared to slave labor
because you don't need to give anyone
any benefits you don't need to give
anyone a living wage
when they're illegal and when they enter
illegally they of course usually
predominantly vote
blue they vote democrats so those
democrats offer benefits exactly
and protection exactly or they just pay
them under the table i've seen that
happen
the democrats will offer protection so
they'll say like we won't you know in
like sanctuary states like california
for instance
but then what happens is the
corporations in california there's
there was this running scheme they did
in in southern states where
they would put ads out in mexican city
like small town mexican newspapers
saying
we will pay you a thousand dollars a
month to work in this processing plan
the people would show up and it's a very
very menial job like
just take it off the rack put it in the
machine the machine does the work
just at the end of the month the company
would call ice
eyes would show up oh my god arrest them
all send them back there's a lot of evil
corporations taken advantage
of illegal migrants and no one really
wants to talk about it because it goes
against the agenda of
we want more immigration but when we
look at the larger immigration policies
of this country they have extensively
hurt
so many people i remember being in
tijuana during the border crisis when
there was a rush
on the border when they tried to run
through the wall
and i remember being in this kind of
occupied field of individuals that
traveled from nicaragua from honduras
from el salvador
lied to people who were taken advantage
of
every way up every different country
that they went into there was a bunch of
coyotes there was a bunch of cartel
members that
took advantage of them in ways that i
can't even describe here in the show
because of
you know the i'm not youtuber exactly
but talking to these individuals seeing
their hope and like yes i was promised a
job i was promised work i was promised
prosperity
and then let's be honest here when a lot
of them do come they're exploited for
the full benefit of the multinational
corporations
and then these soulless heartless
individuals or keep promoting come on in
come right in there information yes
these these are the democrats there's
there's a a
i have a family member who's just like a
die-hard blind
neo-liberal doesn't know anything
doesn't read but thinks he's super smart
and it's the perfect example
of of these kind of people who are like
we want to protect these poor immigrants
and it's like you realize they're being
exploited by massive multinational
corporations who want cheap labor paid
under the table with no benefits
and they're like you just you just
you're racist and i'm like
so hateful this is this is what what
they do the democrats will tell you that
voter id is racist
so canada's or canada is what ready
don't they i hope that's right many
countries
many countries usually do i have an idea
every other country on the planet is
racist for not
for for for forcing people to identify
themselves there's a famous video about
i think
about eight years of uh of um
yes going around a yuppie area in new
york no no no no no he goes to
berkeley okay yes yes yes and he asks
the young berkeley college student to
voter id is racist
and they all say yes for for a variety
of reasons and then he goes to harlem
and he asks black people if it's racist
and they're like no why
yeah and then my favorite bit from this
from the bit is like the arguments
my favorite part of the bit one of the
arguments from the left was
they don't know how to get to the dmv
and so he asks that he like walks into
this black dude and he's like
excuse me sir do you know where the dmv
is and he goes oh yeah it's over on 25th
street like the guy was giving him
directions of course he knows where the
dmv
these people are so racist yeah but the
point is when it comes to these policies
that they're implementing the democrats
don't actually
like the regular democrat voters don't
look into what the policies do
it's just an emotional reaction of we
must protect these people
and then it's funny because i see all
these arguments about pro-life versus
pro-choice and they accuse
conservatives of not caring about babies
after they're born and i'm like you
clearly don't talk to any of these
people because they run charities for
these babies
like they donate heavily to this you
don't care about what happens to the
migrants if they get here
and they're being run through these
these major corporations that pay them
pennies on the dollar illegally
and don't give them benefits and they
don't have lawyers or access to fight
back
now i know there are non-profits that
help these individuals too but many of
these voters don't care and know about
that california is the perfect example
of this because when you go to skid row
and you see and you smell and you just
are in this entire mess of of so many
homeless people of so many don trodden
people that the government can't help
and then you see the latte drinking
flip-flop wearing yuppies saying
come on in come everything's going to be
great everything's going to be fun and
then
you see the ramifications of that
there's not enough
you know let's be honest here there's
not enough resources there are not
enough things that could be done to to
help people
a lot of them are left on their own and
when they're left on the alone though
they're screwed and
extorted and exploited by some of the
worst elements of our society
and that needs to be called out and that
needs to be stopped also when you try
and help someone that doesn't want to be
helped i don't know if you guys have
ever done that taking someone into your
house like a
sibling or a friend if a country can't
even take care of its own citizens how
are they going to take care of new
citizens coming in
that's a great point but how do you take
care of someone that doesn't want to
take care of themselves
important aspect that you brought up
there because a lot of people don't want
the help and
they have a mental health crisis that
they're that this country's dealing with
so
something jordan peterson talks about he
says to be very careful about helping
people who don't want to be helped and
even people who do want to be helped
because you
never know if your help is actually
going to be useful to them or if you're
just going to make it worse
and it's such a drain to help someone i
don't know i mean that is a selfish way
of being we're all pretty selfish as
animals we have to think of ourselves
first
and it is exhausting well sometimes you
end up hurting someone more than
actually helping them
and that's you know another important
aspect that you have to kind of consider
and you know the best thing you can do
is instead of giving someone fish giving
teach someone how to fish and give them
a fishing pole yes that too
that's the way i put we're teaching them
how to build fishing poles because uh
well then you got to give them the wood
you got it you got to like teach them
how to chop down trees
you got to start from the beginning
here's how you take a rock take some
obsidian smash it now you got something
sharp now you can cut so i always say
like you can you can teach a man a fish
feed him the rest of his life
but if they don't have a fishing pole
you can teach them how to get them a
bunch of fish with their bare hands i
guess
all right we're gonna use the lasers
that's what i think what's missing
because the left says
give him fish the right says teach him
to fish and i say i think the rights got
a better position on this one of
teaching people how to fish
the left says it too i might want to be
you know overly simplistic but
i think the appropriate response is like
here's a fishing pole buddy here's how
you use it
you're on your own that's it thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you